the ending of morbius comes down to a
big showdown between Michael morbius and
his best friend Milo going toe-to-toe
and clawed a claw to see who's the last
Vamp standing here's everything you need
to know about the final showdown and
those wild end credit scenes
ever since morbius and Milo were
children Dr Emil Nichols has been
responsible for administering the
treatments that keep them alive and
although both men have since moved to
New York City Dr Nichols has moved there
too and continues to care for Milo now
that Milo has transformed into a vampire
however he no longer needs Dr Nichols
and apparently he doesn't feel all that
grateful to him either when Nichols
arrives at Milo's lavish apartment to
give him his latest treatment he quickly
sizes up the state of his patient it's
clear Milo no longer needs his
assistance and for a moment it seems
like Milo will just let him leave but
then Milo lashes out tearing at Nichol's
throat and slashing him across the
abdomen instead of drinking his blood
though Milo leaves Nichols bleeding out
on the floor of his apartment with the
intention of morbius finding him with
the little life he has left Nichols
calls morbius who immediately comes to
help morbius is way too late though he
arrives just in time for Nichols to
weekly ask him to stop Milo and then
breathe his final breath Morpheus is
saddened and astonished by what's
happened but he doesn't have time to
dwell on it because his echolocation
Powers quickly alert him to the fact
that Milo has taken Martine hostage
Michael frantically uses his Newfound
ability to fly to reach Martine who Milo
is left on the roof of a skyscraper
unfortunately Milo has already mortally
wounded Martine and left the scene and
just like he did with Nichols Milos left
Martine just alive enough to allow her
to utter her last words to morbius
before she dies morbius whose
relationship with Martine has recently
evolved from a platonic friendship to a
brand new romance is devastated by
martine's physical state and leans over
her as she instructs him to make her
death count just before she passes away
morbius kisses her and a drop of his
blood falls into her mouth martine's
eyes then closed for the last time and
in a fit of rage and grief morbius
drinks her blood
as morbius gives in to his Primal urge
for real human blood Milo appears on the
roof and applauds his actions morbius
isn't feeling nearly as positively
however and lunges at his friend they
both morph into their vampire faces and
use their special powers to wrestle
across the rooftops of tall buildings
They smash through windows and fall and
fly from place to place and a knock down
drag out fight finally Milo who seems to
have the upper hand pushes morbius off
the rooftop of a skyscraper and follows
him down the pair land in a Subterranean
pit with Milo on the ground and morbius
hanging from a pipe above Milo uses this
pause in their battle to give morbius a
pep talk about their vampiric condition
once again doing his best to convince
morbius that their evolved State isn't a
curse in response morbius shouts drops
from the pipe and lands unconscious in a
shallow pool of water below while
morbius's shout could be taken as
frustration at Milo repeating the same
arguments he made earlier it was
apparently a call to the bats living in
a nearby cave as Milo approaches his
body a swarm of thousands of the animals
fly to morbius's Aid and together hold
his unconscious body upright just accept
in response to the appearance of
morbius's bat allies Milo grabs a pole
from a wall opposite morbius in the bats
and starts to charge toward his friend
with it as he gets close he leaps High
into the air and aims the pole like a
spear Milo obviously has deadly
intentions but morbius is now awake and
seems to direct the bats to hold Milo
off and immobilize him morbius goes to
Milo and stabs him with the antidote he
created while the antidote will cure
Milo of his vampirism it will also kill
him as he lays there Milo tells morbius
that the good doctor can't let him die
when morbius was the one who gave him
his name finally just before his life
ends Milo apologizes in an inversion of
a scene from early in the movie where a
young morbius saved an unconscious
Milo's Life After Milo dies morbius
calls Milo's name and then when he gets
no response he calls his real name
Julian Milo remains quiet as sirens
sound in the distance
the authorities including the FBI agents
on morbi's case arrive at the pit where
morbius and Milo had their final
showdown but morbius is nowhere to be
found then just as the FBI agents look
over the edge of the pit the swarm of
bats emerges with morbius flying in the
middle those bats really seem to dig
morbius morbius had made a second dose
of the antidote that he gave to Milo and
indicated he intended to use it on
himself however he hasn't taken it and
it doesn't seem like he will instead
he's confidently flying with his bats
and seems to be fully in control of his
vampire powers for the first time before
the credits roll Martine opens her eyes
indicating that when morbius's blood
dripped into her mouth earlier it turned
her into a vampire so apparently along
with his various other Supernatural
Powers morbius also has the power to
create other vampires
in the first mid-credits scene Adrian
tombs aka the vulture from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe appears out of
nowhere in an empty jail cell apparently
as a result of Doctor Strange's
Multiverse collapsing spell from
Spider-Man no way home tombs examines
himself in the mirror looking slightly
surprised the scene cuts to a news
report that says his appearing in the
cell could lead to tomb's immediate
release this seems to indicate that
tombs has found himself in a universe
other than his own and one where he's
not a known criminal the second
mid-credit scene starts with an alive
and robust looking morbius driving in
the middle of nowhere he stops by a
non-descript field and gets out of the
car the wind blows around him and then
tombs arrives wearing a very elaborate
vulture suit tombs proposes a team up
and morbius seems to be considering it
as the scene and movie officially ends
apparently tombs is enjoying his freedom
in this new universe and has decided to
get a gang together of similarly
anti-heroic individual tools starting
with morbius does this mean that a
Sinister 6 movie will finally happen
only time will tell
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one